bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo en compagnie
cette semaine de delphine girard bonjour
45 minutes à passer ensemble pour passer
en revue l'actualité politique et
parlementaire avec cette semaine
l'arrivée à l'assemblée du collectif
budgétaire 2012 en vedette la
suppression de la défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires qui était l'une
des mesures phare de nicolas sarkozy
l'opposition évidemment est monté au
créneau
rénover la vie publique c'est la mission
qu'a confié françois hollande à lionel
jospin avec un rapport attendu début
novembre
l'ancien premier ministre devra plancher
sur le cumul des mandats ou encore la
réforme du statut pénal du chef de
l'état dans sa commission une ancienne
ministre ump roselyne bachelot enfin le
parti socialiste prépare son congrès de
l'automne l'élection de son nouveau chef
cette semaine c'était le ramassage des
copies des contributions tous en rang ou
presque derrière le texte de martine
aubry et jean-marc ayrault
il y a bien sûr quelques indisciplinés
qui ont déposé leurs propres textes
comme le ministre benoît hamon ou encore
comme vous marie noëlle lienemann
bonjour aux gens ministre sénatrice
socialiste de paris
alors vous représenter l aile gauche du
parti vous êtes une proche de benoît
hamon vous avez d'ailleurs signé sa
contribution on y reviendra
et vous avez également apporter votre
propre contribution vous l'avez vous
même qualifié d' un peu raide pour
l'europe parce qu'elle a rencontré un
succès cette contribution on a plusieurs
députés parlementaires on essaie cette
parlementaire on a des premiers
secrétaires du parti socialiste on a
aussi des des responsables des
secrétaires nationaux puisque les quatre
premiers signataires sont jérôme guedj
qui est le présent conseil général de
l'essonne et nous avons emmanuel maurin
et marianne louis secrétaire nationale
et moi même mais on a aussi des
ministres plus chevronnés comme paul
quilès gens au cou
jean le garrec donc vous avez le mélange
des générations n'a pas tous la même
histoire mais on est tous convaincus
qu'aujourd'hui se joue beaucoup de la
réussite de ce quinquennat de la sortie
de crise de ce pays et que c'est à
travers une réorientation réelle et pas
formelle de l'union européenne que que
nous devons passer mais aussi par des
choix qui par exemple ramène l'état le
capital public dans l'économie parce
qu'on réindustrialiser rap à la france
et notamment avec sa mutation
technologique et écologique
sans cet investissement public lourd en
irak les régions nous pensons aussi que
la question des salaires n'est pas un
handicap à la con à la productivité et à
la compétitivité
bref nous pensons qu'on peut réussir à
gauche on va en certains pensent qu'on
en reparle et un de tout ça mais
certains pensent quand même beaucoup que
la réussite du quinquennat dont vous
parlez passe par la discipline du parti
c'est en tout cas un peu le message
qu'ont fait passer contre il s'agit pas
d'être indiscipliné
il ya un congrès si c'était un congrès
ça sert à quoi ça sert à aller battre
moi je suis quand même très très étonné
d'abord on a l'expérience on sait que si
on n'est pas capable
au début du pied 2 du quinquennat
d'avoir les vrais débats qui traversent
la société française notamment
l'électorat de gauche
ce n'est pas capable d'être en écoute
avec ces populations avec ses attentes
et de la facture se paye au moment de
l'élection dans cinq ans et on ne peut
pas faire comme si la question de 2002
est définitivement derrière nous donc le
débat que veut françois hollande avec
les partenaires sociaux faux vous l'ayez
aussi en interne
oui oui alors il ya des choses tout à
fait drôle que j'apprécie beaucoup dans
la contribution de jean marc ayrault et
de martine aubry dont chacun a bien vu
qu'il souhaitait je ne veux voir qu'une
seule tête il est écrit le parti
socialiste est un parti de débat avec
l'ensemble des forces autour de nous le
premier débat c'est avec ces militants
avec ses adhérents les primaires n'ont
pas affaibli notre candidat le débat
interne n'affaiblira nine parti ni notre
gouvernement alors my noëlle lienemann
on va dérouler ensemble fil de la
semaine si vous le voulez bien
et lundi à propos de fil ça détricote à
l'assemblée en ce début de semaine les
députés examinent le projet de loi de
finances rectificative pour 2002 qui
prévoit 7,2 milliards de recettes
supplémentaires au menu notamment
l'abrogation d'une mesure phare de l'ère
sarkozy la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
désormais les salariés paieront des
impôts sur ces heures-là reste à définir
à partir de quand et là lundi ça
cafouille un peu jamie hartman a à quand
la fin des heures supplémentaires
défiscalisées
toute la journée le gouvernement et sa
majorité ont multiplié les déclarations
contraires finalement matignon souhaite
une entrée en vigueur au 1er août alors
que le rapporteur du budget à
l'assemblée le socialiste christian
eckert évoque la date du 1er juillet
mesure peut-être d' équilibre et
peut-être de nature à assurer une bonne
information pour ceux qui n'auraient pas
entendu dire pendant les campagnes
électorales que les heures
supplémentaires ne sont plus encouragés
par l'argent public
ce matin encore semaines christian
eckert proposer par voie d'amendement
la date du 1er janvier 2012 autrement
dit une application rétroactive de la
mesure qui aurait permis près d'un
milliard d'euros d'économies pour les
caisses de l'état
oui mais voilà à cette date là françois
hollande n'était pas encore président de
la république et les salariés qui
effectuent des heures supplémentaires
n'étaient pas censés savoir qu'elle
serait soumise à l'impôt
devant les protestations de l'opposition
le gouvernement a donc retardé la mise
en application de sa mesure même si on
nous dit juillet senuc janvier demi
scandale ça reste un scandale
sous la pression ils ont reculé pas
assez nous ne voulons pas qu'il y ait de
remise en cause de la défiscalisation et
rétroactivité au 1er janvier ou au 1er
juillet ça reste un scandale sans nom
car sur le fond l'objectif du
gouvernement reste lui inchangé
récupérer les 5 milliards d'euros que
coûtait chaque année depuis cinq ans les
heures supplémentaires défiscalisées
cher à nicolas sarkozy alors un coup 1er
juillet 1er janvier puis finalement
premier route vous avez dit que c'est
l'activité parlementaire qui veut ça le
débat parlementaire
ça donne quand même cette impression
d'un cafouillage sur un sujet qui
finalement toucher au pouvoir d'achat et
moi je pense que bon c'est aussi la vie
parlementaire faut pas surestimer ce qui
est quand même important c'est
finalement ce que voter en même temps ça
veut aussi dire que c'est très important
que le gouvernement travaille en bon
l'entendement je ne sais pas qui je ne
suis pas l'assemblée on est au sénat
j'ai personnellement je pense que ça
veut dire que quand même le gouvernement
de travailler au près serré avec les
parlementaires pour que s'il ya des
désaccords réels des choses sur lequel
on veut infléchir ce soit clair mais que
ce soit pas sur des choses qui
apparaissent finalement assez
incompréhensible pour nos concitoyens
est la rétroactivité vous la trouvez pas
injuste c'est un principe habituel qu'on
essaie de combattre un de d'éviter la
rétroactivité là il y avait quand même
un autre collègue eckert avait soulevée
quand même quelque chose c'est qu'il ya
eu des des heures supplémentaires
d'opportunités nous savons par exemple
que pendant un certain nombre d'années
les heures supplémentaires ont été
substitutives à l'augmentation des
salaires parce qu'évidemment on mettait
des heures supplémentaires j'allais pas
dire fictif ce que je suis passé jean
lui faisait ou pas mais ont gonflé le
quota d'heures supplémentaires pour
éviter l'augmentation des salaires parce
que c'est elle et a finalement qui
paient cette mesure donc on a vu aussi
que dans la période du début d'année
un certain nombre d'entreprises ont
utilisé cette méthode pour booster un
peu certains voilà donc composer
contraire mais aussi quand même servir
de façon honnête mais absolument aller
je vais pas lâcher tout comprendre de
soucis très franchement je pense que le
1er août est très sérieux je pense que
cette mesure doit être expliquée
comprise et il faut pas qu'on ait un
débat sur la périphérie du sujet le vrai
sujet c'est que c'était pas une bonne
mesure ni pour l'emploi c'était pas la
vraie mesures pour le pouvoir d'achat et
s'était par ailleurs
un des éléments qui comptent qui a accru
le déficit public alors vous connaissez
les critiques qui sont faites par
l'opposition sur cette mesure ce sont
surtout les classes moyennes et les bas
salaires qui profitait de cette
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
évidemment les députés de l'opposition
et notamment d'anciens ministres sont
montés au créneau cette semaine extraits
vous êtes devenu le parti des bobos mais
j'habite rue des martyrs rue des martyrs
je veux dire les bobos les bobos qui ont
voté pour vous cela ils sont pas
concernés par les yeux refus mais le
comique bouger la rue des martyrs
lui il a besoin des 500 euros c'est cela
qui sont les cocus de la gauche et vous
êtes devenu le parti des bobos des
petits bourgeois est pas le parti des
ouvriers françois hollande pendant la
campagne de façon constante a toujours
promis solennellement qu'il ne
toucherait pas aux exonérations de
cotisations sociales pour les salariés
dans les entreprises de moins de 20
je le cite dans une des réponses qu'il a
fait à l'émission de rtl où il était
interrogé par un ambulancier qui lui
disait monsieur hollande je vais perdre
mes cotisations sociales avec ce que
vous prévoyez est la réponse qui a été
faite par monsieur hollande je vous le
promets monsieur je maintiendrai les
cotisations sociales sur les heures
supplémentaires pour tous les salariés
des entreprises de moins de 20 salariés
c'est un flagrant délit de mensonge
politique
oui vous faites sauter le bouclier
fiscal mais c'est pour mieux mettre un
boulet fiscal à la france qui travaille
est ce que c'est une mesure de bobo la
fin de mai a dit des choses inexactes
car justement ce qu'elle m'a tenus pour
les entreprises de moins de 20 salariés
c'est l'exonération des cotisations pour
les entreprises
parce que dans ces entreprises là créer
de l'emploi en substitut aux heures
supplémentaires est beaucoup plus
difficilement comprennent rien c'est que
dans ces entreprises de moins de 20
salariés les salariés qui ont fait des
heures supplémentaires rollin pays et
des impôts ans mercredi de cotisations
sociales de l'entreprise seront exonérés
comme elle était auparavant pour la
raison suivante grand mas tenu promesse
exactement ce qu'il a
et n'eut alors pour autant il faut bien
expliquer le sens de cela alors quand
aux bobos laissez moi rire la grande
masse des ouvriers à travaux t pour
françois hollande en tout cas nettement
plus que pour nicolas sarkozy
et c'est eux qui bénéficié en majorité
de cette exonération des heures
supplémentaires vous d'accord enfin les
ouvriers ou les employés toute façon ils
s'étaient pas les gens qui sont forfait
donc il faut faire de 10 heures horaire
pouvoir des heures supplémentaires donc
bon c'est vrai que c'est plutôt le monde
du travail
1 tc rarement les cadres supérieurs bon
pourquoi cette mesure est juste parce
que comme je vous le disais il ya
d'abord eu beaucoup d'opportunités de
substitut à ce qui devrait être
normalement dans une entreprise
l'augmentation des salaires deuxièmement
parce que ça a rendu plus facile les
heures supplémentaires dans les grandes
entreprises plutôt que la création
d'emplois et cela c'est aussi les
ouvriers c'est aussi des employés quand
vous êtes demandeur d'emploi vous êtes
aussi dans ces milieux-là 3 et donc si
on veut soutenir le pouvoir d'achat et
là on n'a pas de leçon à recevoir de
l'opposition ce n'est pas par ce
mécanisme là qu'on doit le faire bon la
troisième raison c'est quand même con et
avec un déficit financier très important
donc quand on veut combler le déficit
faut d'abord faire rentrer les
ressources fiscales légitime il n'est
pas normal qu'une heure travailler
normalement ou quelqu un qu une
augmentation de salaire va payer des
impôts sur cette augmentation de salaire
et celui qui ferait une heure
supplémentaire ne paierait pas d'impôt
dessus c'est d'ailleurs ce principe
constitutionnel d'égalité de traitement
qui rendait difficile si même nous
l'avions souhaité d'avoir un traitement
différencié sur la fiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires entre les petites
et les grandes entreprises
voilà donc c'est une bonne mesure
maintenant elle ne peut pas à elle seule
résoudre les problèmes il faut
s'attaquer à l'amélioration du pouvoir
d'achat je pense par exemple aux heures
supplémentaires des enseignants qui
faisait des études et autres
c'est sûr qu'il va falloir discuter
quand même on ne peut pas dire aux
enseignants
il faut créer des postes mais ils ont
aussi pas si bien prémunir et que cela
donc pour réfléchir sur leur grille
salariale et
et c'est un paquet qui doit être négocié
entre la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires qui est pas une bonne
méthode et la relance du tout cas au
moins dans un premier temps de maintenir
l'effort fiscal maintenant lehmann va
être demandé aux français en 2013
c'était un apéritif l'un 33 milliards de
recettes à trouver à tout en fiscalité
les 33 milliard 71 milliards de déficit
à combler moi j'ai envie d'une
croissance sont maintenus aussi en
revenons un petit peu à l'europe
vous vous dites que finalement il ne
faut pas ça revient un petit peu c'est à
dire que il le faut si on ne signe pas
le traité on ne respecte pas les
engagements alors je distingue le cheval
dans le débat sur l'europe je distingue
deux choses le court terme et le long et
moyen terme
quand on vote un traité européen comme
c'est le cas de ce qui nous arrive à
être nous est proposé on fait des choix
dans la longue durée qui traite le court
terme et le moyen long terme comprennent
bien très très très brièvement vous êtes
d'accord pour respecter les engagements
notamment de 3% sur les 39 ans je suis
je suis d'accord pour les respecte et je
pose la question du délai pour la tan
que ce soit un an près ou deux cents
près si c'est pendant l'année si vous
prenez un an de plus pour atteindre
l'objectif ou deux ans de plus pour
atteindre l'objectif est que pendant ce
temps là vous avez remis en route le
moteur de la croissance
c'est beaucoup mieux que d'atteindre
l'objectif en ayant complètement plombé
la croissance et les capacités de rebond
et quand même vous êtes quand même
d'accord pour les jeunes et les ongs
également par les engagements de la
france je suis une vraie qui me va faire
cavalier seul dans l'ordre mais ce n'est
pas une question de cavalier seul je
suis d'accord on assimile on respecte
mais elle prend du temps et surtout
discute avec nos partenaires on n'est
pas les seuls avec devant ça depuis
qu'on a signé le traité d'amsterdam ont
il ya eu au moins cinq six sept ans où
la plupart des pays n'ont pas atteint
les objectifs
et c'est là où le système vicié des
objectifs de co2 déficit publique et
d'endettement devrait être calé par
l'ensemble des pays de l'union où ceux
de la zone euro sur un des legs par
exemple audi pendant cinq ans ont fait
tomber nos déficits à tel niveau
et on investit avec de l'emprunt à des
niveaux et parce que du point de vue du
cadre économique dans lequel nous vivons
il ya des moments où il faut relancer et
des moments où il faut engranger les
fruits de la croissance pour réduire les
déficits et donc ça ça doit être des
choix politiques décidées par des
représentants élus ça doit pas être
gravé dans le marbre une fois pour tous
et 0,3 ou bien la c3 et maintenant c'est
zéro c'est à dire qu'on tue toute
possibilité de ce que j'appelle une
politique keynésienne c'est à dire une
maîtrise qu'on appelle contracyclique
par rapport à l'économie
c'est à certains moments faut booster à
d'autres moments il faut rééquilibrer
on ne prend pas en compte la différence
entre une dépenses ordinaires de
fonctionnement et les dépenses
d'investissement qui compte pour
l'avenir c'est pas la même chose de
donner une aide sociale parce que les
salaires sont trop bas que l'économie
nous fait plein de pauvres et cet argent
n'est pas très productif même s'il n
humainement nécessaire et puis
d'investir de l'éducation dans les
grandes infrastructures tout il faut des
choix politiques
ce qui ne veut pas dire des choix
laxistes on va passer à un autre sujet
marie noëlle lienemann 1 c'est l'une des
annonces de l'intervention
présidentielle du 14 juillet la création
d'une commission sur la moralisation de
la vie politique
promesse de campagne de françois
hollande c'est à l'ancien premier
ministre lionel jospin reçu ce lundi à
l'elysée que revient la charge de
présider cette commission mais il ne
sera pas tout seul à exercer cette
lourde tâche sandra sert qu'à retirer de
la vie politique depuis dix ans mais
très actif dans la campagne
présidentielle
lionel jospin revient aux
responsabilités il va présider la
commission sur la rénovation de la vie
publique
les sujets qui l'attendent sont nombreux
la recherche d'un
meilleur déroulement de l'élection
présidentielle avec un regard notamment
sur le statut juridictionnelle du chef
de l'état une réflexion sur la réforme
des cibles des modes de scrutin pour les
élections législatives et sénatoriales
et puis enfin le troisième grand champ
de réflexion s'engage entre dans les
détails va concerner des règles de
déontologie permettant d'assurer une
meilleure transparence à la vie publique
une commission paritaire qui comporte
quatorze membres des universitaires des
hauts fonctionnaires mais aussi et c'est
une surprise
roselyne bachelot a par l'ancien
ministre ump et lionel jospin
aucun membre net issu d'un gouvernement
ce que regrette la patronne des
sénateurs communistes qui dénonce un
manque de diversité politique
pour les écologistes la composition de
cette commission doit être modifié à
droite on s'interroge sur son utilité
c'est une commission jospin formé de
gens qui ne font plus de politique ou
qu'ils n'ont jamais fait qui va dire
comment doivent être faites les
élections politiques on peut pas en
parler au parlement
ça sert à quoi le parlement la
commission jospin se réunira dès le 25
juillet un rapport doit être rendu début
novembre
alors c'est le grand retour de lionel
jospin qu'est ce que vous en pensez
écoutez je pense surtout que des sujets
comme cela c'est de la compétence du
parlement
je garantis pour une fois pas exagérer
moi je pense que revaloriser le
parlement est une question centrale dans
notre démocratie
le rôle du parlement c'est de faire du
travail qui prépare les décisions
politiques de l'exécutif sur des grands
champs où il faut que c'est quand même
pas des experts qui vont décider de ce
que nous trouvons normal de faire dans
le mode de scrutin de faire dans parce
que c'est vrai aussi de votre bouche et
des deux
et de mon facteur c'est vrai de tous les
citoyens pourquoi des grands experts
vous croyez qu'ils n'ont pas une idée
sur la manière dont leurs problèmes
peuvent remonter à l'assemblée comment
le mode de scrutin permet d'être sûr que
tous les territoires du dernier des
petits villages jusqu'aux quartiers de
nos grandes villes puissent être
entendus vous croyez que les élus sont
moins compétents que ces experts la même
part ils peuvent parfois être enfin ils
le sont d'ailleurs partie prenante
ce qu'ils sont les mieux placés
finalement pour décider de leur sort je
pense qu'au cumul des mandats dont on va
parler un petit peu plus tard pour
considérer jugé qu'ils vont voter
de toute façon c'est eux qui vont voter
donc pour avoir un vote le plus en
avance possible il faut mexes le
parlement en situation d'assumer sa
responsabilité et de l'assumer
face au public moi je préférerais une
commission préparatoire avec les
l'ensemble des représentants des
parlements avec des auditions publiques
car comme on le fait d'ailleurs très
souvent au sénat avec des prises de
positions chacun assume ce qu'il est
plutôt que d'essayer de faire croire
qu'on va trouver des consensus qui de
toute façon n'auront pas lieu ou de
croire qu'on va pouvoir contourner les
politiques dans dans leurs votes
en revanche les politiques faut qu'ils
se sentent engagés et les commissions
doivent pas servir de prétexte
je crois qu'on en reparlera tout à
l'heure le cumul des mandats il n'y a
pas besoin de commission dire un seul
mandat
il n'y a pas besoin de 25000 travaux
c'est maintenant qu'il faut le faire
alors si c'est pas cette c'est sûr ça
doit être impérativement la suivante et
qu'on ne fasse pas toi lienemann donc
c'est un peu la commission de trop mais
sur le fond il y avait un besoin de la
réalisation ils eurent absolument tout à
fait fondamentale rénovation profonde et
parmi ces rénovations galles poilleux le
pouvoir du parlement parce que quand
vous n'avez pas une responsabilité
directe s'est jamais de la faute de
personne dans ce pays kantienne d'un
vote
quand on annonce est pas de ma faute
c'est bercy c'est ceci ou cela faut que
les politiques assument ce qu'ils votent
ce qu'ils font est donc oui et puis il y
à moraliser il ya à vérifier aussi que
la diversité de l'agd du cadre politique
est bien représenté la question de la
proportionnelle est une question
centrale qui peut pas être contourné en
même temps il faut trouver un système
qui se stabilise l'institution parce que
bon par exemple de ce point de vue soit
l'exemple portugais sur l'exemple
allemand il ya de la proportionnelle et
en même temps c'est dit régime stable
donc il y a il ya moyen de vous disiez
passé le début donc de votre réaction
sur cette commission il ya que des
experts il ya quand même roselyne
bachelot c'est une façon pratique
l'ouverture comme l'avait fait nicolas
sarkozy alors bah écoute et j'espère que
le gouvernement va pas pratiquer
l'ouverture parce qu'on a vu le succès
de cette affaire
l'ouverture est un mythe qu'on soit
attentif à respecter l'opposition est
nécessaire moi je suis pas d'accord très
souvent avec l'opposition
je pense qu'elle a une fonction
impérieuse utile en tout cas elle de sa
tâche elle avoir même quand c'est nous
déplaît bon donc le pouls le droit de
l'opposition c'est très important mais
faire croire qu'ils ont brûlés car qui
en a qui ceci qu seraient ouverts parce
qu'on va déboucher 3 non ça chaque fois
qu'un gouvernement ou qu'un président
fait ça ça s'est retourné contre lui et
ça finit par le fait que sa majorité
perd des élections
même quand c'était nous là on va parler
devant un des cumuls du cumul des
mandats et mardi c'est le sénateur
claude dilain qui revient à la charge
avec une pétition contre le cumul des
mandats
il est au menu de la nouvelle commission
jospin et provoque des remous au sénat à
claude dilain relance le débat avec une
pétition que vous avez signé marie
noëlle lienemann après son élection au
sénat le parlementaire socialiste avait
démissionné de sa mairie de clichy sous
bois sandra cerqueira
il s'agit bien d'une remise au point
l'appel lancé par claude dilain contre
le cumul des mandats visent à faire
taire ceux qui pensent que la promesse
de campagne aurait du plomb dans l aile
je ne fais rien d'autre que dire ce qu'a
dit le parti socialiste et qui a été
voté par les militants de dire ce qu'a
dit le président de la république est ce
qu a dit le premier ministre dans sa
déclaration politique générale donc j'ai
pas l'impression d'avoir fait une
révolution mais les réticences
persistent ils ne sont pour l'instant
qu'une vingtaine avoir signé l'appel
si la loi passe un jour il ne sera plus
possible de cumuler mandats
parlementaire et exécutif local y
renoncer c'est pour certains élus ce
coupé des réalités du terrain et des
pays qui font de leur deuxième chambre
l'assemblée des territoires c'est le cas
de l'allemagne quand c'est un exemple 25
fois par jour sur tous les sujets et
nous on est en train de faire le
contraire pour faire face aux
résistances une solution de compromis
serait à l'étude
pourquoi pas continuer à accumuler mais
à condition que ce soit à la tête d'une
petite ville s'agit-il de trouver
l'effet de seuil
partir de quel type l'exécutif de quel
type de démographie il est souhaitable
de faire ceci ou de faire cela entre une
commune de 3500 habitants et une grosse
ville il faudra trancher
c'est donc là dessus que devrait porter
le débat au risque de rogner sur la
réforme qui au départ porté sur le
mandat unique alors marie noëlle
lienemann on l'a dit on vous l'avait
signé cette pétition pourtant le sénat
constitutionnellement se veut le
représentant et le représentant des
territoires ce qu'on peut comprendre
quand même qu'il ya un besoin d'un
ancrage local pour les sénateurs et vous
n'avez pas besoin d'avoir en même temps
de mandat pour nous pour avoir un
ancrage local
vous pouvez en avoir eu un vous pouvez
rester ancrée sur votre territoire sans
être père sans être présent causé
général s'en est à tête d'un exécutif
avait été vous à une époque est député
et maire absolument générale est
incompatible
c'est pas que c'est incompatible c'est
que j'ai observé aussi d'abord à
l'époque où j'étais il y avait moins de
décentralisation et à l'époque on était
moins directement la gestion mais je
plaide coupable
c'était éprouvant et c'est vrai qu'au
bout d'un moment on délègue beaucoup
alors moi j'ai toujours travaillé dans
ma mairie j'ai toujours travaillé en
équipe
ma première adjointe où mon premier
adjoint blanc deuxième mandat avait
beaucoup de responsabilités mais pour
être franche j'ai coaché contre eux que
je lui en ai juste pas souhaité que les
ministres cumulent pas j'ai quitté ma
demande mammeri mon premier adjoint est
devenue mère et il est toujours maire et
franchement je n'ai pas de remords de
ces décisions vous êtes simplement
sénatrice je suis en soit voilà
absolument et je suis pour un mandat
unique parce que à l'expérience j'ai vu
que ce n'est plus possible et alors
après c'est le directeur de cabinet
c'est le premier adjoint c'est le
secrétaire-général fin maintenant
directeur du service dans les mairies
qui finalement font l'arbitrage en lieu
et place du maire ou qui vient juste de
temps en temps et c'est tout moi je
pense que de réticences de la part des
sénateurs la réforme a quasiment du
plomb dans l aile
la vue lors du discours de jean marc
ayrault ici de nombreux sénateurs sont
montés au créneau en disant qu' on ne
suivra pas le gouvernement dans ses
doigts ils ne voteront pas que vous
voulez on va pas non plus moi je vais
pas mettre un flingue au devant chacun
de mes collègues qui les voyaient les
corps voyez là c'est l'illustration que
médicaments les experts parfois sont
mieux placés pour stationner de pas eu
les parlementaires parce que je respecte
plus le collègue aura le courage de
voter contre d'assumer son vote
call expert qui va donner des leçons qui
n'est obligé les personnes qui sont
arrivées ou ici veille voté contre et
c'est pas forcément le bon choix c'est
en tout cas ce que évidemment mais il
m'arrive que mes collègues vote contre
ce que je pensais que le bon choix
je leur dis simplement les collègues il
faudrait que s'explique devant le peuple
et c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
de râler dans ses couloirs et de lever
sa main pour dire non non j'en veux pas
du cumul des mandats a donc justement
moi je préférais voyez plutôt qu'une
commission d'experts qu'on dise monsieur
dit là on le met à la tête d'ing
d'une commission de parlementaires pour
faire des propositions en vue d'une
proposition de loi ou prochain pendant
le à l'automne alors on va continuer à
voir l'actualité en ce sens mardi
toujours un discours attendu de françois
hollande sur le thème de la fin de vie
le président de la république est en
déplacement dans une maison médicale à
rueil-malmaison dans les hauts-de-seine
il avait promis pendant sa campagne
d'envisager une révision de la loi
leonetti il propose de créer une mission
de réflexion sur la fin de vie en écoute
peut-on aller plus loin dans les cas
exceptionnels où l'abstention
thérapeutique ne suffit pas à soulager
des patients aux prises avec une douleur
irréversible et qu'ils appellent un acte
médical assumer un travail de réflexion
d'information de concertation sera donc
conduit et j'ai confié la mission de
mener ce travail au professeur didier
sicard ici présent président d'honneur
du comité consultatif national d'éthique
dont qu'on comprenne bien la loi
leonetti prévoit le laisser mourir il
s'agirait là d'aller plus loin avec un
mot à dire un geste actifs plus actif
dans certains cas très précis
c'est bien ce que françois l'on ne
prononce pas le mot d'euthanasie c'est
un sujet tellement sensible que le mot
ne peut être prononcée vous voyez bien
que dans l'histoire l'euthanasie
elle a quand même eu des connotations
extrêmement redoutable
il s'agit pas de d'une hta nazis au sens
de dire les gens sont pas utiles vont
terminer bon il s'agit d'accompagner la
personne dans sa fin de vie par une
maîtrise autant que faire se peut de
d'elle-même un de ces choix de la
manière de faire avec toute la
difficulté en fin de vie selon les
circonstances de pouvoir exprimer son
avis si je puis dire avec liberté
autonomie et conscience donc de ce point
de vue le sujet évidemment complexe et
pour le coup je pense qu'on ne peut pas
se prendre une décision nouvelle sont
deux conditions la première à voir bien
évaluer l'effectivité de la mise en
oeuvre de la loi léonetti et de son
efficacité ou de ses limites parce que
elle est quand même que de 2005 un l'air
de rien ses longs que les pratiques se
mette en oeuvre dans les domaines comme
cela et deuxièmement je pense
qu'effectivement faut aller plus loin
parce qu'on a tous vécu autour de nous
des épisodes familiaux douloureux où on
a eu le sentiment que la loi telle
qu'elle était ne répondez pas ou bien
être de fins de vie des de nos proches
donc je pense qu'il va falloir la
changer cette loi l'améliorer là si je
puis dire lui ouvrir des champs nouveaux
je pense que peut-être la précaution
nécessaires avec toutes les précautions
et ne pas confondre les mots
l'euthanasie c'est quand vous dites je
vais août à nager c'est vous même qui
décide et pour l'autre là c'est pas du
tout l'euthanasie alain d'aucune une
commission qui est qui est créé sur ce
thème là bien particulier mais de façon
générale ça fait déjà deux commissions
en mission de réflexion en deux jours
plus toutes celles qui ont été annoncées
avant est ce qu'on crée trop de ça fait
un peu mou ça fait un peu moins terrain
de sienne
alors c'est pour ça qu'il faut quand
même à mon avis bien distinguer les
enjeux ce qui était clairement affirmée
et qui peut être mis en oeuvre
rapidement parce que l'engagement était
clair et la mise en oeuvre n'est pas
d'une complexité folle voilà donc ça par
exemple le cumul des mandats moi je peux
entendre des 3500 habitants
bon faut quand même aller au coeur de
cible donc il faut un parlement qui
puisse rapidement décidé bien des cas où
il faut négocier que les partenaires
sociaux je pense par exemple tout ce qui
était sur le grand sommet social par
exemple les licenciements économiques
bon il faut un peu négocier parce que
c'est sûr qu'on peut pas bon mais il
faut une date butoir et dans la
commission tomber démission mais pas
trop et bien souvent des tables bien
ciblées et des dates butoir soit pas de
premier pas marie noëlle lienemann vers
le congrès du parti socialiste qui se
tiendra à toulouse fin octobre avec la
présentation des contributions route
vers le congrès au parti socialiste
c'est la journée des contributions avant
l'émotion qui détermine les rapports de
force
alors il ya celle de martine aubry et de
jean marc ayrault qui entend rassembler
les socialistes
mais benoît hamon se veut le grain de
sel le grain de sable du conseil
national le ministre délégué à
l'économie solidaire et chef de file de
l'ailé gauche du parti compte bien faire
entendre sa voix jean baptiste daoulas à
l'entrée du conseil national benoît
hamon fait figure de mauvais élève du
gouvernement il est le seul ministre à
avoir signé une contribution différente
de celle de martine aubry et jean-marc
ayrault
d'abord il y avait pas de consignes
on était le premier ministre donne pas
de consignes c'est pas son tempérament
il est chef du gouvernement d'un chef du
gouvernement il ya chef bien sûr mais de
l'action du gouvernement après il ya le
parti a le groupe etc
mais le chef de la majorité se chargent
de siffler la fin de la récréation
j'ai eu une discussion avec lui il est
membre du gouvernement je souhaite qu'au
moment où on soumettra au vote des
militants un texte une motion nous
soyons tous rassemblés pour inscrire
dans la durée le travail que la gauche
veut faire au service du pays en clair
signé une contribution différente passe
encore mais pas question de soutenir une
motion différente lors du congrès
l'autre grande inconnue c'est l'avenir
de martine aubry
des rumeurs ne cessent d'annoncer son
retrait ou un nouveau bail à la tête du
ps essayez d'éviter d'écrire des papiers
tous les jours en expliquant ce sont mes
états d'âme c'est moi même qui ai dit
que je souhaitais quitter le parti
socialiste
dès que les conditions étaient réunies
je crois qu'un grand pas est fait
aujourd'hui le sort de martine aubry
sera connue au plus tard le 12 septembre
c'est à cette date que l'émotion seront
déposées la motion aubry héros devrait
bénéficier d'une majorité écrasante
leur contribution a réuni aujourd'hui 88
% des parlementaires et 75% des
secrétaires fédéraux du parti le ps a
aussi renouvelé ses cadres en nommant
des jeunes et des femmes au secrétariat
national
vous avez salué à la motion à la
contribution 1 2 benoît hamon est-ce
qu'on peut être au gouvernement et
défendre une contribution à une motion
différente de celle du premier jour fait
ça s'est toujours fait jean pierre
chevènement quand président mitterrand
était président de la république au
congrès de prendre et certains à déposer
des motions qui ont recueilli 15 20%
dans le parti et jean pierre chevènement
quand il a quitté le ps était bien après
ça n'avait rien à voir
jean luc mélenchon pour l'appliquer vous
que dans ce gouvernement c'est
finalement tous les mises se soit rallié
alors qu'ils avaient chacun des
impressions je pense qu'il ya une
amicale pression comme on dit
dans avec les formules diplomatiques
habituels une amicale pression qui les
amenés à être dans l'obligation de
signer sept dit pas qu'il était en
désaccord a confirmé cette pression on
dit qu'il ya des consignes avaient
envoyé enfin la question et l'émoi de la
consigne c'est un climat quand on vous
dit on a écouté la jean marc ayrault
pour qui j'ai un grand respect que je
trouve un bon premier ministre
mais enfin on va pas faire un congrès du
ps pour compte le gouvernement moi je
déposerai probablement une notion avec
mes amis et d'autres parce que nous
avons des désaccords sur certains sujets
ou en tout cas nous voulons infléchir un
certain nombre de décisions qui
n'étaient pas dans les 60 engage prendre
de françois hollande qui nous engage
tous quand on est dans une situation où
on doit avoir un débat c'est évidemment
pas les pour et les contres gouvernement
enfin où l'on vit et la crise ne
justifie pas l'unité
c'est un petit malin c'est le même débat
sur l'unité nationale y aurait une crise
dont au contraire
la grande question c'est quelle est la
sortie de crise est là il doit y avoir
débat il ya des gens qui vous disaient
il n'y a pas de problème la crise est
telle que savard met en cause le système
j'observe que paradis fiscaux produits
dérivés der des der régulation bancaire
écrasement de l'économie réelle par
rapport à l'économie financière tout ça
continue comme un rouleau compresseur
alors qu'on aurait pu penser que la
crise allait amener un autre politique
j'observe une autre chose c'est quand
les une alternative qu'elle cherchait à
les chercher vers l'intégrisme l'extrême
droite où les pensée totalitaire jeudi
si la gorge en mai n'est pas un
montebourg n'a pas signé de contribution
et arnaud bon à renouer aussi au front
de deux sujets majeurs 1
kiko qui correspondent aux sujets qu'il
a posé avec des rues très bon moi je
respecte chacun je suis en train de
donner des de faire des bons points et
de morale jeudi par contre le droit du
militant et le devoir du militant du
cadre politique de dire ce qu'il a à
dire dans le respect
des règles de notre parti est de
l'efficacité du gouvernement
c'est un impérieux devoir en début de
quinquennat sinon on aura des retours de
bâton
difficile alors parlé d' arnaud
montebourg pardon donc peut-être un mot
sur martine aubry
vous pensez qu'elle doit ou qu'elle va
se représenter comme combien c'était moi
je fais comme elle j'écoute ce qu'elle
dit je crois ce qu'elle dit voilà qu'est
ce que l'on va pas commencer à être vert
jeudi blanc je fais noir 1
et ben non elle a dit elle va faire elle
dit quoi le dis plus rien ne dit pas
quels sont alors appelés laquelle avait
pris des engagements que si cette
audition sur l'énergie ça c'est très
très subjectif
bien sûr mais elle est en train de vous
dire la réunion là que tout à l'heure
que elle pensait que ça allait dans le
bon sens donc moi je fais comme elle je
constate de toute façon les premiers le
premier secrétaire ne sera plus élu par
un vote alternative au suffrage
universel puisque c'est obligatoirement
la tête de liste de la motion des deux
motions majoritaire qui peuvent se
présenter
les deux motions en tête pendant qu'ils
peuvent se présenter et donc de fait ce
sera celui qui ont été cooptés dans la
motion majoritaire
arnaud montebourg donc on en parle a
poursuivi cette semaine ses
consultations avec les acteurs du drame
social de psa peugeot-citroën rencontre
avec les syndicats de l'entreprise puis
mercredi avec le président philippe
varin qui avait déclaré auparavant
n'avoir pas d'autre choix que de fermer
le site d'aulnay supprimer 8000 emplois
ce même mercredi étaient entendus à
l'assemblée l'ancien pdg de renault
louis schweitzer
pourquoi la marque au losange se
porte-t-elle mu aujourd'hui que son
concurrent français peugeot réponse
fermeture d'aulnay et est incontournable
pour psa mais au fond quelle est la
différence on dit renault va un peu
mieux que ps en ce moment au fond quelle
est la différence mais que renault a
pris le contrôle de nissan que renault a
fait dacia est que
renault a géré le camion avec volvo donc
au fond c'est en allant à l'étranger
qu'on s'est évité un certain nombre de
problèmes en france
voilà la solution c'est de produire à
l'étranger
j'ai beaucoup d'amitié pour lui je fais
de serre je pense quand même qu'il faut
un peu nuancé parce que je ne veux pas
défendre peugeot je pense que j'ai j'ai
lu l'interview de monsieur peugeot dans
le figaro je pense quand même que il a
tort de monter le ton comme cela et
j'espère que les esprits vont se
pacifier parce que quand même quand on a
un pdg d'une entreprise qui vous
explique que non non non la feuille qui
a sorti la cgt c'est pas vrai c'est faux
il y aura jamais ça et que c'est
exactement ça qui se déroule
bon on peut appeler ça avec les mots
pudiques qu'on veut c'est quand même un
mensonge bon et ce n'est pas simple pour
la négociation sociale et le dialogue
d'un autre pays mais néanmoins
n'accablons pas que peugeot peugeot a
moins fait partir hors de france oui
mais il nous arrive aujourd'hui
mais justement une partie de sa
production et faire croire que l'issue
de peugeot ce serait de faire comme
renault je ne suis pas d'accord avec
cela qui est des alliances stratégiques
avec d'autres à l'étranger pour exporter
oui externalisée à l'extrême les la sous
traitance en dehors du pays
non maintenant c'est doit être un devoir
et je rappelle que l'état est
actionnaire de renault a toujours la
prendre le coût du travail
arrêtez de dire il ya un problème de
coût du travail attendez en temps réel
mais elle est pas réel avec l'allemagne
bon donc en allemagne le coût du travail
dans l'automobile est supérieur au coût
du travail en france donc
et que ce soit sous traitance ou
production donc la réalité c'est aussi
que l'allemagne a fait des choix de
gamme qui correspondait au fait où le
coût du travail sur les gammes élevé à
moins d'impact sur les gammes petit je
ne dis pas qu'il n'ya pas de question à
voir sur le calcul notamment des
cotisations sociales depuis des années
ceux déjà sous jospin et déjà son hyper
ans je disais le calcul des cotisations
de social doit être fait sur la valeur
ajoutée dans l'entreprise et pas sur la
masse salariale
et pourquoi même pas d'avoir une vision
un peu différente
de ce calcul selon les secteurs très
exposée à l'exportation ou où les
secteurs qui ne sont pas quand vous
pensez que l'essentiel de nos
allégements de cotisations touche auchan
carrefour
franchement c'est pas pour ça qu'ils
vont être une pierre une caissière de
plus il y sert quand même les boulons et
il bénéficie davantage donc je dis il ya
un vrai sujet de repenser les grandes
filières industrielles de ce pays avec
les acteurs qui sont maîtres delà de
l'argent public dans certains jeux quand
je l'aï l'état est actionnaire
m les moyens aussi neil walker mais peu
c'est le cas pour renault et je veux
absolument que les entreprises et
j'habite à ce que nos amis puissent lire
le blog de madame karine berger
économiste désormais député les modes de
calcul de rentabilité dans l'industrie
aujourd'hui c'est ça doit être rentable
en un an
on sait qu'il faut c'est en six ans du
cycle faut organiser pour que
l'investissement long terme et la
rentabilité à long terme soit revalorisé
par rapport au court terme alors
repasser au jeudi très vite quand un
député réclame plus de transparence dans
les comptes des députés et en ce jeudi
c'est le député centriste charles de
courson qui persiste et signe il va
déposer un amendement pourtant rejeté en
commission ils demandent que soient
fiscalisés et surtout contrôler les
frais de mandat des parlementaires
de quoi s'agit-il valérie brochard
soizic bonvarlet en ce début de 14e
législature et de majorités socialistes
les députés s'apprêtent et il a voté
l'abolition des privilèges
apparemment pas puisque le 11 juillet
dernier la commission des finances a
rejeté massivement l'amendement du
député udf charles de courson visant à
fiscaliser l'indemnité représentative
des frais de mandat salle des quatre
colonnes les députés n'ont pas
franchement envie d'évoquer le sujet
j'ai même pas dit des sources
rien du tout l'unité n'est
représentative de frais de mandat ad par
les propos
c'était une proposition d'amendement en
commission des finances il a été rejeté
monsieur niveau l'indemnité d'un montant
de 6000 412 euros mensuels doit
permettre aux députés de faire face aux
dépenses liées à l'exercice de leur
mandat non prises en charge par
l'assemblée distingue de l'indemnité
parlementaire principal salaires
proprement dits des députés et en
complément du crédit pour l'emploi des
collaborateurs lire fm doit permettre la
prise en charge du loyer de la
permanence parlementaire et des frais
liés aux déplacements ou cérémonies
officielles
problème une partie de l'indemnité étant
souvent inutilisés et sans contrôle
existants lire fm peut être détournée à
des fins personnelles récemment
mediapart accusé le député socialiste
pascal terrasse de s'être offert des
vacances avec son rfm le mélange à la
fois de ce qui relève de mes indemnités
d'élu donc je peux faire ce que je veux
de mounir et pme je pense que médiapart
s'est un peu trompé sur le fond de leur
coeur des suspicions que charles de
courson voudrait faire taire en
soumettant à l'impôt sur le revenu la
partie de la rfm non consommés
impliquant un contrôle par
l'administration fiscale des dépenses
des parlementaires
visiblement c'est un sujet sensible à
voir la réaction à des députés
interrogés dans ce reportage
est ce que c'est il faut qu est ce que
vous vous l'auriez voté l'amendement de
charles de courson
je pense que la bonne méthode c'est le
contrôle par les assemblées elles mêmes
par un collège de père de l'usaj de ces
fonds sur lequel les sénateurs comme les
députés les sommes qui sont donnés me
paraît sa fin il faut bien les nuancer
son brut 1
c'est pas vrai que tous les mois il ya
7000 100 euros qui tombent chez le
hémois aberrant que soit comme quoi on
contrôlait justifier l'injustifiable
manquant juste mais éventuellement
versés lorsqu'elles ne sont pas utilisés
interdit éventuellement renverser quand
elles sont pas utiliser intégralement
alors en prenant un laps de temps de
deux trois ans parce que les vous une
année vous allez rénover le siège de
votre local cette année là vous dépensez
plus vous changez votre ordinateur
encore qu'on a dû d'autres ça normal
mais en même temps la maman était rejeté
ça c'est drôle ça suppose que c'est là
c'est bercy qui va venir voir comment
les
député et vont commencer à dire oui mais
pourquoi vous avez fait ça est ce que
c'était bien votre mandat et vous
commencez à la commanderie recodifié ce
qui procède de la manière d'exercer son
mandat ce qui ne me paraît pas sain dans
une démocratie
au passage merci ne peut pas contrôler
les comptes des parlementaires sas au
nom de la séparation mène quant à ainsi
les aroud les impôts sur le revenu il
contrôle des impôts sur le revenu mais
l'irs fn doit être contrôlée par
l'assemblée par un collège de père voir
qu'ils puissent avoir quelques grands
sages qu'on associe mais pour l'instant
voilà ça il faudrait merci beaucoup
c'est la fin de cette émission c'est la
dernière de l'année
on se retrouve donc en sabrant il dit
bon ça on remercie évidemment toutes les
équipes qui nous ont aidés à faire cette
émission cette année à commencer par
eléonore picot est évidemment toutes les
équipes en régie merci beaucoup ont
sillonné au revoir et merci à vous deux
est ainsi